[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public on est
ensemble comme tous les jours du lundi
au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat
vous le savez la promesse et dans le
titre de l'émission donne du sens à
l'actualité se mettre au service du
public vous proposer des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici les titres du jour on
l'attendait depuis un mois là du
gouvernement àal 2 est imminente en tout
cas c'est l'information qu'on nous donne
ce sera une équipe sans François baayrou
ça c'est certain le président du MoDem a
claqué la porte hier soir ouvrant une
crise politique dans la majorité
présidentielle des accords sur la ligne
politique ou ambition personnelle
peut-être un peu des deux bien ce sera
notre premier thème juste après ces
titres et puis en seconde partie de ce
sens public notre nouveau rendez-vous
tous les 15 jours jusqu'au 9 juin date
des élections européennes avec cette
question que fait l'Europe on se posera
cette question sur plusieurs thèmes
l'énergie c'était il y a 15 jours
l'immigration la gestion de crise la
transparence et ce soir la transition
écologique avec la présidente de la
Commission européenne qui vient
d'annoncer une pause dans la réduction
des
pesticides la proposition sur les
pesticides est devenue un symbole de
polarisation elle a été rejetée par le
Parlement européen il n'y a plus de
progrès non plus au conseil il faut donc
faire quelque chose et c'est pourquoi je
proposerai au collège de retirer cette
proposition la colère des agriculteurs
freine le virage écologique européen
mais le Green Deal le pacte vert
était-il pour autant trop ambitieux
l'administration européenne doit-elle
revoir sa copie tenir mieux compte de
l'impact social de cette transition
réponse dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
donc ce coup de tonnerre signé François
baayrou est raconté par Samia de
chien il a finalement dit non hier
François Baayou a annoncé qu'il
n'entrerait pas au gouvernement
pressenti depuis 48h pour remplacer
Amélie ouea Castera à l'éducation
nationale le président du MoDem
n'occupera finalement pas le poste en
cause une différence d'approche avec
l'exécutif qu'il juge rédibitoire sur la
méthode à employer j'étais persuadé
qu'on peut redresser l'éducation
nationale en peu d'années mais que ça
demande
un choix politique qui est de faire ça
avec les enseignants et les autres
parties prenantes de l'école pardon mais
c'est pas le cas de la personne qui sera
nommée non mais vous vous voyez bien on
est on est sur un fond
de de une musique de fond qui est au
fond les enseignants travaillent pas
assez les autres membres du MoDem sont
libres de rester ou d'entrer au
gouvernement François baayerou assure
que son parti appartient toujours à la
majorité
présidentielle une position
d'équilibriste que lui reproche
plusieurs élus du MoDem remonter contre
une décision prise sans concertation
préalable si nous n'étions vraiment pas
satisfaits de la place qui nous était
proposé il eû été envisageable de
pratiquer le soutien sans participation
nous sommes en train de choisir
l'inverse la participation sans le
soutien en refusant d'entrer au
gouvernement François Baayou fragilise
une majorité présid
déjà mal en point le président de la
République a un problème avec sa
majorité puisqu'il n'a pas de majorité
depuis 2022 et le problème c'est quelle
ligne politique quelle ligne politique
quelle cap François Baayou va plus loin
qu'une simple critique de la politique
gouvernementale il n'exclut plus d'être
candidat à la présidentielle 2027 mais
il lui faudra d'abord en finir avec les
ennuie judiciaire le parquet de Paris a
fait appel de sa relaxe dans l'affaire
des assistants européens du
MoDem en refusant d'entrer au
gouvernement François Baayou a-t-il
lancé la course à la présidentielle 2027
on en débat tout de suite avec Sophie
dravinel bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
grand reporteur au service politique du
Figaro Franck Morel bonsoir et bienvenue
avocat associé chez Fichi Granger ancien
conseiller social de d'édard Philippe
amatignon de plusieurs ministres
également et expert à l'Institut
Montaigne on attend Bruno cotess le
politologog qui arrive dans un instant
ça c'est le bonheur des taxis parisiens
les jours de pluie voilà la circulation
dans la capitale Tam Tran bonsoir Tam
bienvenue éditorialiste politique allez
une question assez générale pour
commencer Sophie dravinel que vous
inspire on a dit coup de tonner on aura
pu dire coup de théâtre on peut dire
psychodrame bref il y a plein de de
qualificatifs ce psychodrame baayrou
est-ce que c'est une histoire d'ego de
ligne politique c'est un peu tout berou
François berou c'est quand même une
figure de notre politique nationale je
pense qu'il aurait fait peut-être qu'il
fera mais plus globalement il aurait
fait un excellent président de la
République sans doute c'est vraiment une
une figure qui était qui était vouée à
ça et son son son regard sur l'état est
est très clairement solide pensé il n'y
en a peu comme lui première chose euh
ensuite c'est vraiment quelqu'un du coup
de particulier effectivement et du coup
dans le le le monde politique dans son
parti il a toujours il a toujours géré
euh son parti un peu seul la décision
qu'il a prise là il l'a pris sans doute
aussi très seul et c'est une décision
qui lui appartient lui c'est pas une
décision de parti de formationou on
reviendra d'ailleurs ça aura peut-être
des conséquences à l'intérieur du mod
absolument on a déjà vu aujourd'hui
qu'il y avait plusieurs réactions on en
parlera et et ça ça dit beaucoup quelque
chose pour moi de de ce qu'est
l'homme on ignore si vraiment il a été
tenté de prendre un un poste ou si c'est
une posture il y a eu des tractations
bien sûr sans doute pour la défense sans
doute que il aurait été très bien je
pense dans un poste qui qui qui qui lui
correspond très bien sur mélange de
politique de la ville d'aménagement du
territoire de démocratie de rapport avec
les Français un grand ministère
spécialement pour lui aurait été
excellent et aurait vraiment répondu à
ce qu'il pote très bien qui est un
problème de relation entre la population
françaises et les élites pour
caricaturer un peu oui on peut
d'ailleurs ce sera au cœur du du second
thème de notre émission puisqu'on va
parler de la la transition écologique du
pacte vert européen et finalement de la
difficulté pour les citoyens il y a les
agriculteurs mais pas seulement
européens à acceptter à intégrer la
rapidité de ce de de cette transition et
de cette transformation euh Franck Morel
euh quel elle est la part de calcul
politique quand même d'après vous dans
la décision de François Baayou oh
indéiablement c'est ce que vous disiez à
l'instant il y a toute à la fois une
question d'amour propre ça et qui
conduit plutôt à quelque chose d'un peu
éruptif et d'un peu immédiat il est
comme ça il est peu comme ça
effectivement il a pu avoir dans le
passé effectivement des des réactions
qui pouvaient se se placer sur ce
registre on a par exemple en tête le
long feuilleton de de ces relations très
conflictuelles avec Nicolas Sarkozi par
exemple mais on voit bien dans les mots
qui sont choisis qu'il y a une petite
partie qui relève de ça quand il évoque
par exemple le fait qu'il s'agirait
d'une démarche je cite d'une démarche
d'humiliation on voit bien que c'est un
petit peu sur ce terrain de l'ego de
l'amour propre qu'il se situe mais
évidemment ça n'est pas que cela et vous
l'avez souligné à juste titre il y a
aussi une démarche d'analyse politique
et d'ailleurs les deux sujet sur lequel
il s'est positionné pour justifier sa
position c'est un sujet lié aux
relations territoriale relation France
d'en haut France d'en bas Paris et reste
de la France et puis le sujet de
l'éducation pour expliquer en
particulier pourquoi une éventuelle
proposition de ministère des armées ne
ne cochait pas cette case ne permettait
pas d'aller dans cette direction alors
après il y a un aspect qu'il faut
souligner dans un
quinquena qui est compliqué euh dans le
fait que le président actuel ne pourra
pas se représenter dans le fait aussi
que sous la 5e République on n jamais vu
une majorité sortante être réélu sur son
bilan sauf en 2022 mais dans des
conditions très particulières et bien un
une dose de recul on va dire une dose de
gouetououi il faut il faut sortir il
faut sortir d'ailleurs ça vous pour
édard Philippe aussi oui est un acte
politique voilà qui qui est posé en la
matière alors vous vous avez évoqué
l'une et l'autre la la la proposition ou
l'hypothèse
du ministère de la Défense écoutons
François Baayou donc il était ce matin
l'invité de nos confrères de France Info
et il a évoqué lui aussi cette
proposition il est très clair on me l'a
proposé on dit on vous on vous propose
de prendre le ministre des Armées le
ministère des armées c'est le seul
secteur à mes yeux c'est le seul secteur
qui va à peu près bien en tout cas qui
relève les défis dans lequels nous
sommes c'est la c'est la c'est le c'est
le résultat de la politique suivie
depuis 5 ans et je n'allais z pas me
donner le ridicule d'aller marcher sur
les plat de bandes d'autres ministres
dans le secteur qui je considère est à
peu près le seul exemple de de remise à
niveau et de remise en en vocation de
notre pays Sophie drvinel effectivement
restons un instant sur cette hypothèse
ministère des armées il y avait pas
grand-chose à faire ça roule tout seul
ou alors qu'il y avait quand même un
défi à relever il y a évidemment en
matière de défense en matière régalienne
en matière internationale en matière
intérieure puisque la défense est quand
même très impliquée il y a évidemment un
travail énorme la seule chose c'est que
ce travail est beaucoup fait à l' lé et
que donc évidemment c'est comme d'avoir
placé monsieur séjourné au Kor Stéphane
séjourné un ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui est à minima une chose un
peu surprenante et
donc je pense que chez François Berrou
il y avait évidemment l'idée de ne pas
vouloir perturber un ministère qui
justement a besoin d'une certaine
fluidité ces temps-ci parce que que la
menace est réelle et François beou qui
est un très fin en matière de politique
internationale le sait le sent et donc
sans doute n'avait pas non plus envie de
de de basculer et de bousculer mais il
n'avait pas non plus envie d'être sur
sur un ministère qui de fait était
dirigé par Emmanuel Macron je pense et
qui est tout le temps à l'international
et qui est sur ces questions de défense
extrêmement engagé donc ça c'est un
point euh après je pense aussi
effectivement qu' n'avait pas envie pour
parler un peu facilement de se cramer
euh voilà et et et et je sens que vous
avez envie de développer là je vouis é
je voulais évoquer un point qui me
paraît très signifiant dans cette
affaire c'est qu'on ne peut pas
s'empêcher de rapprocher trois faits
politiques qui mis ensemble crée un
cocktail un petit peu compliqué le
premier fait politique c'est le temps
interminable que prend ce remaniimement
ou et le fait que on ne peut pas
s'empêcher ça va faire un Mo Mo demain
voilà ça
faire et on ne peut pas s'empêcher d'y
voir un vrai un vrai souci un vrai
problème en terme de fonctionnement voil
sais peut-être qu'on va avoir la
composition dans quelques minutolument
mais quand même même si on l'a tout à
l'heure ça a pris beaucoup de temps et
ça montre quand même ça révèle quand
même quelque chose de de d'embêtant en
terme de fonctionnement le deuxième fait
politique c'est le sondage qui est paru
je crois ce matin et qui pour la
première fois Mar alors certes valeurs
actuelle mais c'est un sondage qui
révèle quelque chose d'extrêmement
préoccupant c'est le fait que Marine Le
Pen face à Édouard Philippe ou face à
Gabriel Atal fait soit 5050 soit 51 et
gagne c'est la première fois on n jamais
eu un sondage d'une telle nature je je
avec toutes les limites on est à 3 ans
plus de 3 ans du scrutin et puis on on
sait aussi que ça intéresse
toujours on peut faire notre contre
critique hein d'être les PREMIERS quand
on est patron de médiia à dire ah voilà
pour la première fois marine le même si
était à 47
48 c'est déjà énorme et dans ce sondage
elle est très très loin devant au
premier tour et donc ce deuxème fait
politique est extrêmement marquant et on
peut pas s'empêcher de le rapprocher trè
fait de l'attitude effectivement de
François Barou de François Baayou
vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel Macron mais
également des remous que provoque
l'attitude de François Baayou au sein du
modem ou et donc du débat qui ne peut
pas manquer de survenir sur le
positionnement des différents acteurs de
la majorité au sein de la
majorité intervenir François Baayou on a
eu l'impression qu'on avait attendu
quand même la décision du tribunal lundi
pour voir sil les pouvoir rentrer dans
la danse du gouvernement donc finalement
que mercredi dis c'est moi qui refuse de
rentrer dans la danse c'est quand même
d'une grande ironie dans cette séquence
si longue depuis lundi disons pour la
deuxème partie du remanement l'autre
sujet c'est que on a entendu François
Baayou dire quand même faire des offres
sur l'éducation nationale notamment et C
tous les jours sur les interviews qu'il
a pu faire expliquer à quel point
c'était un sujet important et et en
réalité quand on y pense un peu à
postériori on dit c'est V que ça aura
été quand même difficile parce qu'on
sait que François Baayou éétait opposé à
la nomination de Gabri Gabriel Atal
comme premier ministre que lui son
candidat c'était Julien de Normandie
alors être nommé à l'éducation nationale
pour venir appliquer le programme de
Gabri Gabri avait clairement dit je je
emmène ce thème avec moi à matigon c'est
vrai que ça aurait été très très
compliqué on imagine quand même qu'on
allait au devant de certaines
difficultés relationale important ti
est-ce qu'on pourrait dire sophineinel
que Gabriel est peut-être
soulagé et non seulement on peut le dire
mais ensuite on peut on peut même
peut-être avancer qu'il ne souhaitait
pas que François ber rentre au
gouverement peutêtre même peu gagé je
pense qu'il y avait une forme de bras de
fer et que Bruno Lemire ne le souhaite
pas plus et que finalement ils sont
assez nombreux à se dire bon ben françot
et lui il il fait avec d'une certaine
façon parce que il sait bien qu'il il y
a pas vraiment de place pour lui il du
côté de de
oui on voit bien de la part du Premier
ministre que Gabriel hatal qu'il y a on
le comprend on imagine bien qu'à sa
place on nurait pas non plus envie de
s'encombrer d'une figure pareille dont
je vous disais au départ qu'il est quand
même très fort mais aussi très présent
très encombrant d'une certaine à l'appui
de ce que vous venez d'indiquer
il a dû être relevé je crois dans dans
ce qui est ressorti que la proposition
relative au ministère des armées émanait
plutôt de Gabriel Atal que d'Emmanuel
Macron ce qui peut éventuellement dans
un billard à plusieurs bandes aller dans
le sens de ce que vous indiquiez tiens
on accueille Bruno cotterè qui va faire
une entrée mais alors franchement ça
s'appelle soigner son entrée bonsoir
Bruno il était sympa votre chauffeur de
taxi bon c'est bien un peu en retard
mais très sympa C politologue chercheur
au CNRS et au bienvenue à vous c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous accueillir
sur le plateau de de sens public bon
évidemment on on on a ouvert ce débat
sur le la crise politique parce que
c'est peut-être le terme qu'il faut
employer ouverte par le le la décision
de François Baayou de de refuser
d'entrer au gouvernement à tale numéro 2
comment vous l'analysez-vous est-ce que
vous parlez de crise politique tiens le
mot est peut-être un peu fort il faut
attendre de voir le comportement des
parlementaires et du parti du mouvement
on voit que on voit que ça cré des
vagues à l'intérieur du mouvement on a
entendu Jean-Lou boulange ce matin il y
a d'autres réactions les ministres
modemes euh les rumeurs semble dire que
les minunistes modem retrouveraient
leurs postees donc voilà on va on va
voir que ça va créer pas mal de
perturbation une turbulence mais quand
même il y a quelque chose qui est
derrière on voit du point de vue du
président du MoDem il est dans une
opération au fond de se réapproprier
l'idée du centre et ce qui nous explique
depuis quelques heures et peut-être
aussi depuis quelques semaines c'est que
d'après lui cette idée aurait été un peu
travestie averti par l'exercice du
pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron et que lui il
entend maintenant se réapproprier son
idée à lui le ha de gauche et de droite
c'est lui le centre c'est lui pour
toujours et donc c'est un peu ça qu'il
est en train de d'ailleurs il avait
donné une interview je crois que c'était
à nos confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui
en France disant le centre va gagner en
207 et quand je lisais ça moi je je je
le sous-titre je lisais François Baayou
va gagner en 2027 mais ça on va on va y
revenir vous citiez la réaction de
Jean-Louis bourlange député MoDem des
des hautes scènes c'était sur X enfin
l'ex Twitter euh on va on va le lire
hein le modème est en pleine incohérence
les mots sont forts hein euh François
Baayou a décidé sans aucune concertation
avec personne d'afficher un désaccord de
fond avec la majorité présidentielle
tout en recommandant aux députés de
rester à bord et de participer au
gouvernement il ajoute Jean-Louis
bourlange c'est politiquement inepte
moralement dégradant euh alors c'est
peutêre pas une crise politique mais
c'est quand même un peu une crise à
l'intérieur du MoDem t les tontons
flagur pas mal une répque
d' ce niveau et en interne on imagine
que les mots sont encore plus dur encore
plus fort et c'est ce que je disais
peut-être maladroitement au départ mais
que c'est cette
volonté unique de François berou
finalement figure politique presque
solitaire indépendante de son mouvement
et d'ailleurs avec Mariel de sarnè tous
les deux il fonctionnait de cette
façonlà et c'est quand il y a eu
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron du
macronisme globalement que ils sont entr
à l'Assemblée au Parlement avec une plus
de et évidemment au gouvernement et
c'est là où on voit bien aujourd'hui que
et bien François berou trouve face à lui
une vraie défense et une vraie
présence à l'intérieur du MoDem à
l'intérieur du gouvernement parce
qu'évidemment beaucoup attendent d'être
renommé ou d'y entrer je pense à
boncatel ou à d'autres et de fait ça ça
joue pour lui pour son avenir et il sait
que c'est fragile et je pourrais faire
une petite analogie avant de laisser ma
par allez-y allez-y une petite analogie
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça paraît un peu
étrange ah mais je suis assez d'accord
avec vous dans dans la catégorie entre
guillemets vieux chef je dis ça avec
beaucoup de respect mais onut
compareroui et donc surtout que Emmanuel
pardon Jean-Luc Mélenchon a annoncé dans
un meeting hier qui lancerait de la
prochaine bataille et donc on sait bien
tous nous les commentateurs moi je le
suis depuis 2009 j'ai jamais imaginé
qu'il allait lâcher la main et donc là
il a dit hier je vais y aller et on les
voit tous les deux finalement se dire
mais regardez aux États-Unis c'est quand
même alors ils ont beau Jean-Luc
mélenchant décrit les États-Unis il voit
bien que les leaders s'y représentent
voilà donc ça leur fait pas peur je vous
redonne la parole Bruno mais Franck
morrel est-ce que le modème peut
imploser avec cette histoire ou ou pas
je j'exagère un peu en disant ça
justement ce qui est intéressant c'est
de mettre ça en perspective historique
par rapport à d'autres périodes de la 5e
République où s'est posé la question
pour un mouvement politique qui n'était
pas le principal mouvement politique de
la majorité d'organiser de manière plus
ou moins solidaire ou avec plus ou moins
de recul sa participation au
gouvernement et on peut prendre deux
exemples l'exemple de Valérie
giscardestin au début de la 5e
République avec le général de Gaulle qui
s'est terminé quand même par un appel à
voter non en 1969 au référendum et au
début c'était plutôt le 8 mai d'ailleurs
l'expression 8 mai vient de cette
période et puis plus proche de nous sous
le sous le septena de de Valérie
gicardestin précisément le
positionnement du RPR par rapport au
gouvernement bar et là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les ministres issus du
RPR dans le gouvernement bar étai
clairement sur un positionnement qui
était un petit peu dissident et un petit
peu en marge du positionnement de
l'appareil politique on a en souvenir
Robert Boulin alin perfit effectivement
par exemple pour ne prendre que ces deux
exemples qui étai pas vraiment dans la
ligne de Jacques Chirac à l'époque qui
était une ligne beaucoup plus critique à
l'égard du gouvernement et donc on voit
bien avec ces deux exemples historiques
qu'une ligne de distance tout en étant à
l'intérieur de la majorité n'est pas
évidente à tenir parce que il faut
garder un certain équilibre alors on
pourrait prendre aussi encore plus
récemment mais c'est plus un exemple de
personne pour le coup qu'un exemple de
mouvement politique l'exemple du
positionnement de Nicolas Sarkozi
pendant le 2e mandat de Jacques Chirac
où Nicolas Sarkozi s'est construit sur
la rupture sur une différence tout en
étant en soutien du président de la
République de l'époque mais on était
plus sur une personne Bruno cotess
vouliez intervenir mais je je je je vous
pose une question peut-être je reviens à
l'aspect personnel c'est-à-dire euh
alors un un chef qui décide seul c'est
un peu vieux on peut on peut analisé de
deux façons soit on se dit c'est vieux
comme la politique soit on se dit c'est
de la vieille politique vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ou c'est les deux ça
sera toujours là on n'imagine pas même
dans les mouvements politiques récents
modernes qui qui ne cessent de dire
qu'il faut donner la parole aux
militants il faut de l'horizontalité les
chefs continue de de de décider bien
évidemment et les militants l'attendent
les militants s'il y a pas de chef qui
décide il dit ça marche pas le chef ne
che pas donc ça ne marche pas donc une
organisation politique dont l'un des but
est la conquête du pouvoir ça doit
tourner il faut qu'il une personnalité
qui est capable d'incarner l'élection
présidentielle et c'est vrai que même si
à l'intérieur du MoDem ça va faire
beaucoup de vagues sans aucun doute
c'est vrai que pour le moment pour le
modem s'il veut exister dans la grande
compétition présidentielle ils n'ont pas
tritement de personnes ressources en
dehors de de François beou dans les
classements de personnalités politiques
préféré des Françaises des Français il
reste dans dans les 20 personnalités
politiques si on regarde les
sympathisants de renaissance il est dans
leurs 10 personnalités préférées et
surtout surtout ça ressource principale
c'est que dans l'imaginaire politique
français il a installé ce personnage du
centriste et c'est vrai
queme si je me permets aussi de paloi
c'està-dire face à un gouvernement qui
pour l'instant on attend on attend le la
la version élargie du gouvernement àal
pour l'instant très Friden ou parisien
voilà chez les centristes sans doute
effectivement il ressuscite aussi un peu
ce mythe du du du du centriste qui est à
la fois dans la majorité mais qui en
même tempsi p P à maignerie aussi comme
personnalité hein qui était emblématique
de ce pointignie alors on a commencé à
l'évoquer mais l'ambition présidentielle
de François Baou on va on va en parler
ensemble et Etam je vous donne la parole
pour quand même évaluer ce ce nouvel
allié critique en quelque sorte bon il y
a toujours eu un aspect critique dans
les pris depposition de François Baayou
depuis quelques mois mais là c'est c'est
monté d' CR quand même effectivement ce
matin j'aiécouté d'ailleurs nos
confrères de France Info interviewé
longuement François Baayou et les
pauvres au bout de 20 minutes
d'entretien il avent toujours pas de
réponse à leur première question leur
question initiale c'était est-ce que
vous êtes vexé ou est-ce que vous avez
un désaccord de fond avec le
gouvernement actuel ils sont retourner
comme ça de minute en minute et au bout
de 25 minutes d'entretien c'est-à-dire à
la fin voilà ce que François Baayou
déclare enfin l'enjeu de 2027 c'est
précisément qu'on arrive à
réconcilier la France qui se bat en bas
avec la France qui décide en haut et ces
chemins c'est vous qui allez le montrer
en 2025
ben je n'ai jamais renoncé à aucun des
devoirs qui sont les miens voilà dans
cette phrase il y a beaucoup de
choses il y a tout effectivement il y a
la critique de François Baou à l'égard
du gouvernement qu'il juge donc trop
techno trop parisien trop lointain il y
a son projet politique à lui la
réconciliation de ces deux Frances et
puis enfin bien sûr son horizon 2027 du
coup bah j'ai obtenu la réponse à cette
première question François Baayou a à la
fois une blessure d'orgueil et un
désaccord de FO avec le gouvernement de
quoi donc nourrir son amb pour la
présidentielle oui tout en restant dans
la majorité c'est toute la difficulté
c'est toute la nuance comment prendre
cette distance avec une majorité à
laquelle on participe écoutez François
Baayou ça lui fait pas peur c'est un
habitué hein l'allieré vigilant l'ennemi
de l'intérieur c'est un rôle qu'il
connaît c'est ce qu'on voit quand on
parcours notamment sa vie politique à la
tête de l'UDF il a d'abord été un
partenaire qui tenait à son indépendance
à l'égard de l'UMP et puis comme
président du MoDem finalement il s'est
mué en ennemi numéro 1 de Nicolas
Sarkozi on se rappelle notamment de son
son livre en 2009 abus de pouvoir qui
lançait la campagne des européennes mais
surtout mettait sur orbite déjà son
ambition pour la présidentielle de 2012
détruire ses alliés d'hier pour relancer
sa trajectoire solo c'est une forme de
destruction créatrice dirons-nous c'est
vraiment une marque de fabrique pour
François Baayou et donc pour vous c'est
ce qu'il tente de faire en ce moment là
avec cette séquence exactement je vais
pas lâcher sur ma destruction créatrice
he c'est ce concept de Ch exactement qui
dit que les innovations viennent
détruire l'existant qui devient alors
obsolète et que c'est ainsi va le
progrès c'est un un concept qui décrit
bien aussi ce qu'a fait Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 où il a quasiment tué les partis
traditionnel à l'époque avec son en même
temps pour incarner une nouvelle façon
de gouverner de transcender l'éclivage
bon la suite on on la connaît c'est plus
compliqué mais ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a
concrétisé à l'époque c'est exactement
ce dont François Baayou avait rêvé mais
pendant des années le fait de dépasser
le clivage droite gauche he vous
regardez tous ces discours il parlait
que de ça notamment en 2017 et c'est
sans doute ce qu'il doit sentir dans un
coin de sa tête comme une injustice he
le fait que l'autre été élu en 2017 lui
qui a été l'inoxidable candidat de 2002
2007 2012 alors vous le croyez trop
vieux pour 2027 bah on l'a dit il faut
regarder juste de l'autre côté outre
atlantique Joe Biden il paraît qu'il y P
Saint- François Baayou qu'il regarde
cette trajectoire avec beaucoup
d'intérêt Joe Biden qui vient d'avoir
donc 81 ans oui enfin Joe Biden qui qui
a quand même ressuscité l'ancien
chancelier moodcle dans dans un
entretien avec des journalistes
américains quelques jours bon on va pas
on va pas faire sur tr
on va pas faire un débat sur les
troubles cognitif de Joe Biden je suis
pas sûr bon bref c'est un modèle
forcémentb c'est pas notre débat mais
mais Bruno C sur l'ambition
présidentielle c'est toujours
intéressant vu vu d'ici moi je me dis
mais comment c'est possible de garder
comme ça ce ce feu là intérieur mais
c'est ce que vous n disiez tout à
l'heure sinon on fait pas de politique
mais oui on ferait pas de politique et
puis au fond c'est aussi ça nous qui
nous passionne dans l'observation et
l'analyse de la politique c'est comment
sont fait ces animaux politiques pour
conser avit aussi longtemps la foi
qu'ils ont qu'un jour ils vont ils vont
y arriver c'est vrai que lui il a
beaucoup beaucoup cette idée je partage
ce qui vient d'être dit ça doit être
terrible ses idées ont triomphé pas sans
lui parce qu'il a joué un rôle
éminentle pe direemmanuel Macron AA sans
pas étél éminent quand on suit les
intentions de vote on voit que dès que
François Baayou se retire en février les
intentions de vote pour Emmanuel Macron
grimpe de 5 si points il faut toujours
rappeler qu'Emmanuel Macron fait 24 au
premier tour en 2017 mais Marine Le Pen
21 mais François Fillon 20 et Jean-Luc
mananon 1958 donc les les 5 si points il
sans le concours de François baayerou
peut-être qu'Emmanuel Macron n'aurait
jamais été au deuxè tour et donc on
comprend mais c'est vrai qu'il a cette
ambition cheville au corps alors les
animaux politiques sont un mélange je
crois moi inextricable qu'on ne peut pas
séparer de passion de conviction pour
leurs idées et d'ambition personnell
c'est inséparable on ne peut pas dire
c'est des cyniques qui courent après le
pouvoir ou ce sont des idéalistés ce
sont les deux à la fois
ne VO pas leème eux pensent que il ne
cour qu'après la réalisation du grand
projet que la France aille mieux servir
le bien public et que soit assis dans le
faute de l'Élysée et que ce sont les
seuls à pouvoir le faire parce que c'est
ça évidemment c'est ça alors y a quand
même Sophie dravinel une information
importante de de ces dernières heures le
parquet de Paris qui a fait appel de la
relaxe de François Baayou dans l'affaire
des assistants parlementaires européens
du MoDem je sais bien que la justice est
indépendante mais bon est-ce qu'on peut
y voir un lien de cause à effet et puis
alors vous allez sans doute pas répondre
à cette question mais qu'est-ce que ça
peut provoquer justement alors qu'on est
en train de discuter là de cette
ambition présidentielle de du président
du MoDem c'est compliqué parce qu'on a
vu François berou qui est sorti
fanfaronnant sans doute soulagé à juste
titre et on le serait à sa place de
cette de cette situation qui était la
sienne et puis pouf 24 heures plus tard
le le le couprè qui lui retombe sur la
tête ça veut dire que s'il n'avait pas
claqué la porte de l'extérieur et bien
bien il était potentiellement encore
ministre et là et qu'est-ce qui se
serait passé le parquet aurait-il fait
appel on aura jamais la réponse ce qu'on
peut imaginer c'est que en tout cas Éric
Dupont moriti le minist de la justice ne
peut pas appeler le parquet et dire une
donner une instruction individuelle il
ne peut y avoir que des instructions
générales du type soyons
particulièrement sévères sur les délits
routiers et cetera après en plus les
relation entre notre Ministre de la de
la Justice garde des saau et les
magistrats parquetiers sont pas celles
ne sont pas extrêmement fluides
pourrait-on dire et donc on ne peut
imaginer mais sans doute qu'il va y
avoir dans les heures dans les jours
dans les mois qui viennent des propos
politiques qui vont émerger pour dire
bien écoutez est-ce que pour avoir été
désagréable avec le chef de l'État il a
été le parquet l'urait sanctionné je moi
je n'y crois pas parce que depuis un
certain temps le parquet fait quasiment
systématiquement appel c'est quelque
chose qui est régulier c'est quelque
chose qui est quasiment normal depuis
depis une vingtaine d'années je parle
sous V bon alors donc on tire pas des
plans sur la comède d'accord avec vous
mais en revanche en revanche ça peut
avoir des conséquen mais ça aura des
conséquences parce que ça devrait durer
quoi à peu près 1 an d'ici un an il y
aura de nouveau un procès ça va être
plus court parce qu'il y aura que trois
personnes et et si jamais effectivement
il est relaxé très bien mais est-ce que
le parquet va faire un pourvoir en
cassation sans doute pas en revanche
est-ce que lui si il est condamné va se
pourvoir C ép d'amoc qui réapparaît et
alors à ce moment-là on arrive 2027 et
et du coup ça risque de l'empêcher pour
pour
compléter effectivement et et mettre en
perspective dans l'affaire Olivier du
sopt le parquet a fait appel également
donc ce qui montre bien euh que il y a
pas dans ce dossier de volonté
particulière de voilà à priori enfin
espérons difficile à concevoir non il
faut aussi pointer que François Baayou
et le modem ne sont pas les seuls
acteurs qui sont concernés par ce type
de procédure il y a aussi la France
insoumise il y a aussi le rassemblement
national et donc gros dossier voilà sur
le RN effectivement concernant le
Parlement européen et donc ça sera
intéressant aussi de voir comment le
juge en première instance le cas échéant
en appel intervient sur C sur l'ensemble
de ces affaires justement et de mettre
en perspective les éventuelles
différences qui peuvent qui peuvent
exister alors l'image de François Baayou
est-elle entre guillemets abîmée par ce
ce coup de sang je vous propose
d'entendre sur ce thème en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il pense le sénateur LR des
de cèbres Philippe
mouillé je sais pas si c'est un problème
de virage à droite de politique ou c'est
plus la personnalité de François Baayou
je comprends qu'il a souhaité les
lumières au lendemain de sa relaxe mais
le principe de dire je choisis mon
ministère et et si j'ai pas ce que je
veux je claque la porte c'est d'un côté
je suis prêt à être en accord avec le
gouvernement si j'ai le bon ministère et
en désaccord si je n'ai pas ce que je
veux donc je trouve que c'est plutôt un
triste spectacle et ça renforce ni la
majorité aujourd'hui ni l'image de
François B Bruno C votre avis là-dessus
quel c'est toujours compliqué là à chaud
de de de d'imaginer ce que cette
séquence politique peut provoquer pour
l'image la popularité de François Baayou
dans l'opinion française mais voilà vous
vous l'analysez depuis suffisamment
longtemps l'opinion française pour avoir
oui je pense que son personnage à titre
lui personnel est quand même bien
maintenant bien installé dans la vie
politique tout le monde le connaît tout
le monde sait l'essentiel de son
positionnement il a montré à de
nombreuses reprises qu'il était quand
même une personnalité de de de
conviction hein on se rappelle
effectivement son son son débat
absolument terrible avec Nicolas Sarkozy
ce ce ce combat que lui menait au titre
de l'exemplarité en disant voilà on peut
pas donc il a un personnage qui est bien
installé je pense dans l'opinion je ne
suis pas sûr que tout ceci va
fondamentalement bouger l'image de
François Barou si on demandait au
français et au français qui représente
en France vraiment la quintessence du
centrisme politique son nom va assez
vite apparaître par contre c'est vrai
qu'en toile de fond ça contribue à
toujours cette image que nous on étudie
au cvipof on va publier dans quelques
jours notre baromètre de conf ance
politique euh et on va avoir à nouveau
ben les mêmes données structurelles une
vie politique qui est qui est perçue
comme au fond un autre monde un autre
monde les gens sont dans une autre
histoire l'histoire dans laquelle les
gens sont c'est une société qui est
perçue comme pas juste qui donne pas sa
chance aux gens qui ne rétribue pas les
efforts le le mérite et un et un monde
politique qui est dans son univers un
peu autocentré tourner sur nous surtout
vers vers lui-même et donc de ce point
de vue-là c'est vrai que ça ça ça
rajoute un petit peu une couche supp de
complexité les gens voient ça en disant
c'est pas notre monde c'est VO alors que
l'un des arguments d'ailleurs utilisés
par Françis bar pour jus de dire il
faut ça dirait que l'enu central pour
François Baou s'il veut effectivement
préparer la présidentielle de 2027 quel
que soit la longévité de son parcours
c'est de donner du sens à ce qui vient
de se passer c'est qu'il explique
clairement où étai les désaccord de fond
qui l'explicite très clairement et qu'à
partir de là effectivement l'image de
quelqu'un qui préfère rester sur ses
convictions plutôt que de rentrer au
gouvernement alors à ce moment-là ça
peut devenir une image positive mais
alors se posera la question ou se pose
déjà la question de l'attitude des
députés notamment des sénateurs aussi
mais surtout des députés modem dans les
prochaines semaines je propose à Audrey
vetas de nous rejoindre tout de suite
sur ce plateau on va on va s'intéresser
au poids politique du MoDem bonsoir
Audrey bienvenue à vous le poids du
MoDem dans cette majorité rappelez-nous
quelques chiffres alors si le groupe
n'implose pas le modem à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est extrêmement important
Thomas depuis les dernières législatives
celle de 2022 le modem s'est
considérablement renforcé à la faveur
d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron résultat
on recense 51 députés modem sur les
249 qui compos la majorité
présidentielle à titre d'exemple si on
compare avec les députés horizon donc le
parti d'Édouard philiip autre allié de
renaissance les députés horizon c'est 28
députés ça vous donne une idée du poids
du parti de François Baou en gros c'est
un député sur C de la majorité qui fait
partie du MoDem poids important de
François Baayou dans un hémicycle où je
le rappelle l'exécutif n'a pas la
majorité absolue ça vous donne une idée
aussi de l'impact à l'Assemblée si le
modem refuser à l'avenir de travailler
avec la majorité prés et alors au Sénat
des chiffres là aussi alors la présence
du MoDem il est bien plus discrète avec
seulement quatre membres de la Chambre
haute qui sont encartés au Sénat et qui
sont encartés au modem Alain Casabonne
Isabelle Floren Denise SAÉ et Jean-Marie
vanlerbert qui siège dans le groupe
Union centriste alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le groupe Union
centriste au Sénat c'est un groupe qui
est important parce qu'il est capable de
parler à la fois à la droite sénatoriale
et à la fois au gouvernement résultat
entre sa présence prépondérante à
l'Assemblée nationale et dans un groupe
charnière au Sénat François Baou a les
arguments sur le papier pour peser dans
la composition du prochain gouvernement
pour l'instant je le rappelle le modem
ne compte qu'un seul ministre de plein
exercice c'est Marc F à l'agriculture
mais il y en aura peut-être plus
évidemment puisqu'on attend encore les
ministres délégués et les secrétaire
d'État merci beaucoup audre je peux pas
résister à la question parce que j'adore
le bleu roi est-ce que vous avez une
promo sur les vestes bleu roi parce que
je veux je veux
l'adresse on
veadostum en fait on vous avait
pas bref on vaevenir un peu sérieux
quand même qu'est-ce qui va se passer je
peux vous poser la question auon tiens
Sophie dravinel vous qui scrutez la vie
politique de de près là dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines à l'Assemblée on va compter les
voix des modems on va essayer de savoir
quelle attitude ils vont avoir est-ce
que c'est la naissance de nouveau
frondeur pour reprendre l'expression qui
était née à l'époque du du kquenat de
François Hollande alors écoutez oui sans
doute il y a déjà des tensions fortes
hein que qui sont d'ailleurs présentés
aussi bien sur le site internet du
Figaro que dans la format papier deain
et donc que je vous inviterai à lire sur
ces tensions au Parlement relaté par mes
confrères spécialistes de du Parlement
justement euh et et du coup oui
évidemment qu'il y a des frondes qui
montent évidemment qu'il va y avoir des
tensions que ça va déborder ce que nous
disions tout à l'heure ce qui a été très
bien présenté là cette force du MoDem
qui qui qui qui d'ailleurs irrigue
d'autres forces centristes qui veulent
trouver leur place qui ont été frustré
par le choix par exemple de Rachid hadti
à Paris au gouvernement et tout cela
crée des tention je pense à horizon
évidemment
mais ça je je ne sais pas si cela va
aggraver la situation qui est quand même
déjà assez compliquée c'estàd que c'est
un peu la spécificité de ce quinquena
d'avoir des problèmes de majorité c'est
le problème principal d'Emmanuel Macron
qui est quand même dans une drôle de
mauvaise situation et et et c'est assez
on peut pas réduire ça à la vie du
Parlement je pense qu'il y a un vrai
problème dans la majorité présidentielle
qu'incarne Emmanuel Macron dont il
n'arrive pas à se libérer problème de
quoi de cap de de de Lig politique
problème un problème de cap évidemment
parce que il a toujours été faible sur
le régalien sa force c'est finalement
une politique économique qui est assez
cohérente depuis 2017 et c'est aussi une
vision européenne on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'international sans doute
qu'il partage cette vision européenne et
ses choix et cet engagement
international et peut-être d'ailleurs
que l'avenir d'Emmanuel Macron se jouera
à l'international mais euh en dehors de
ça le reste est quand même très
opportuniste et ça se voit et c'est
terrible aussi bien sur les questions de
sécurité avec des ministres qui jouent
un peu de leur influence pour préparer
l'avenir plus que voilà avec des
politiques qui sont à très court terme à
si mois sinon au mois qui vient voire
pour le Parlement à la prochaine loi et
tout cela est extrêmement visible et de
plus en plus aux yeux des Français mais
là on se pose la question de finalement
de la course à la présidentielle qui est
peut-être en partie lancée eu non mais
je sais que c'est dans c'est dans 40
mois c'est dingue de dire ça mais on
pourrait dire aussi que d'une certaine
façon Gérald dararmanin l'a lancé cette
course en annonçant lui-même que il
quitterait il quitterait la place
beauovau euh euh après les Jeux
Olympiques bref et d'ailleurs Édouard
Philippe doit regarder ça avec intérêt
votre ancien patron à matigon évidemment
il doit regarder ça avec beaucoup
d'intérêt non moi je voudrais revenir
sur un point qui me paraît important
aussi vous avez évoqué le fait que euh
l'équation ne se limitait pas euh au
débat au Parlement et à la capacité à
faire adopter en majorité relative un
certain nombre de réformes parce
qu'effectivement par exemple le fait que
le remanement dure quand même assez
longtemps maintenant depuis assez
longtemps maintenant c'est pas une
question de fonctionnement du Parlement
c'est une question de gouvernance du
gouvernement voilà de de fixation et et
vraiment il y a urgence à redonner du
sens à reprendre la main après une
séquence qui avait été plutôt réussie
avec la nomination de de Gabriel Atal à
Matignon avec un discours politique
général assez assez ambitieux assez fort
et on voit bien que à travers ce temps
interminable du remaniement ça amène à
soulever des questions de on pourrait
presque dire de gestion des ressources
humaine parce que aussi bien pour c'est
aussi le manque de ressources humaines
certainement la difficulté si vous
voulez c'est que quand vous faites
l'ambiné excusez-moi du terme des
ministres pendant plus d'un mois quand
vous faites lambiner aussi je pense
aussi aux gens qui ont été qui ont été
dans les cabinets ministériels puisque
j' il pas mal traités mais qui attend
depuis un mois de savoir SS vont pouvoir
continuer ou passer à autre chose bien
évidemment mais ça dit quoi ça dit la
difficulté parfois à attirer des talents
sens pareffectivement ça rend les choses
plus compliqu sur ce thème je vous
interressus pour apporter une voilà une
pièce au dossier si j'ose dire c'est la
réaction de Bruno le président du groupe
LR au Sénat qui était chez nos confrères
de Sud Radio si je ne me trompe ce matin
alors lui il parle d'amateurisme qui est
stupéfiant quand même c'est que je me
souviens que Gabriel hatal a été nommé
le le 9 janvier et nous serons demain le
9 janvier un mois c'est duû jamais vu et
et ça exprime finalement une forme
d'amateurisme parce que quand on modifie
quand on change le Premier ministre
quand on remanie un gouvernement c'est
stupéfiant de voir qu'il faille des
semaines des des jours et des jours
alors que il y a tant d'enjeux tant de
défis qui attendent la France h euh
Bruno cotrress moi je je me projet enfin
je je regarde dans le rétroviseur fin
décembre Emmanuel Macron a pris sa
décision de changer de de de Premier
ministre et sans doute de nommer Gabriel
àal on peut on peut imaginer ça il a il
a pas la liste des ministres qui vont
l'accompagner à ce moment-là enfin ouais
c'est c'est un peu une des conséquences
paradoxales de cette situation il a
effectivement je partage laave ça
soulève plein de
problèmes les Françaises les Français
voient ça mais alors d'une certaine
manière pourrait dire mais alors
finalement si on peut se passer de
ministre pendant plusieurs semaines on
pourrait peut-être s'en passer tout
court comme la Belgique dire la Belgique
ça duré combien de temps la Belgique pas
loin de 2 ans donc voilà ça ça soulève
effectivement en creux l'autre question
de fond qui est est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a des hésitations sur la
direction de ce gouvernement et je
partage totalement ce qui a été dit par
Sophie dravinel je pense que c'est ça le
cœur du sujet en creux malgré la
dimension sans doute personnelle de la
l'histoire avec François beou mais en
creux ça parle de ça c'est au fond c'est
un pouvoir qui est en place depuis pas
loin d'un septéna en fait dans quelques
mois ça fera 7 ans et il est atteint par
les problèmes d'usure c'est-à-dire à la
fois d'usure de ressources humaines
d'usure dans sa capacité à être fidèle à
ses projets de départ d'usure de toutes
les crises qui ont été qui ont été
traversé et d'usure du regard que les
Françaises et les français portent sur
eux c'estàd d'une certaine manière
aujourd'hui il est très difficile
d'expliquer au bout de pas loin de 7 ans
de pouvoir ça y est il y a des trucs
super urgents et il y a un énoncé qui
est oximorique ou totalement
paradoxalours de Gab
je bien sûr qu'il faut euh il faut lui
faire crédit de ce dynamisme il faut
plutôt souhaiter qu'il réussisse et
voilà il il va il va faire ses preuves
sans aucun doute mais il y a une sorte
dénoncée paradoxale qui ait un pouvoir
qui est là depuis 7 ans et qui dit il y
a des trucs super urgents il faut être
efficace maintenant il faut il faut agir
vraiment très vite et donc voilà les
gens perçoivent tout ça je partage
totalement ce qu'a dit sophin les gens
comprennent au fond tout ça pour dire
quelque chose de d'un peu positif
peut-être pour Gabriel Attal aussi on a
eu l'impression au début qu'il allait
être un super porte-parole qu'il allait
être le clone d'Emmanuel Macron qu'il
allait être d'accord avec lui sur
absolument tout qu'il avait pas du tout
eu de prise sur bien son premier
gouvernement là on a l'impression qu'il
y a des vraies discussions quand même et
que Gabriel hatal il montre aussi que
bah il est pas il est pas d'accord sur
tout certainement que sur François
Baayou il avait pas du tout envie de
l'avir dans son gouvernement discussion
on pas le sentiment que c'est lui qui a
décidé que François Baou mais on a
l'impression qu' quand même mais on on
sait que que voilà il y a des vraies
discussions qu'il y a des déjeunés qui
s'enchaînent de 2h30 de 3h dei que bon
bah peut-être qu'il y a quand même une
vraie discussion et que c'est un vrai
Premier ministre voilà à suivre dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines merci à à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat et
à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat